so a recent CNBC article revealed that
76 percent of adults are making
lifestyle changes to prepare for a
potential recession what does this mean
for us as content creators as
entrepreneurs as business owners in this
episode of the think media podcast I'm
going to be breaking down three
recession-proof YouTube strategies for
2023. we're going to be talking about
some shocking stats about the state of
the economy how I personally turned
adversity into an advantage during the
last recession what you can do right now
as a content creator to survive and
thrive in an uncertain economy and why
investing in YouTube and content
creation is the best investment you can
make right now but this is what the CNBC
article revealed it says this 76 of
adults are making lifestyle changes to
prepare for the potential recession 84
of adults say they are concerned that a
recession is on the horizon new survey
shows let me ask you are you concerned
about 2023 about the state of the
economy have you been making any changes
if you watch or listen to the think
media podcast on YouTube of course tell
me in the comments and if you're just
listening of course stick with me but
here's another stat additionally 74 said
their concerns about inflation have
increased and 28 plan to cut back on
holiday spending and so I wanted to make
sure that I record an episode for you
about how do we respond to this how am I
thinking how are we thinking at think
media as we enter into a potential
recession and uh for sure a uncertain
economy well the good news is that
content creators have a unique advantage
in fact there's an article on
entrepreneur.com that the headline was
why creators can weather a recession
better than big business and that's what
we're here for that's what I think media
podcast is all about how can you
position yourself now make smart moves
prepare ahead of time not give in to
fear not get scared but be prepared and
so I've got three big ideas for you and
really big strategies and the first one
is stay on offense
so sure there's fear in the market sure
as we see new numbers come out and
certainly as the FED pushes interest
rates up uh we're gonna see what happens
is the stock market's going down as
maybe how's it at least is Frozen right
now it may see a decrease Supply chains
layoffs and tech companies unemployment
could be rising there's a lot of stuff
happening number one you gotta stay on
offense one of the things I've learned
is that you're not going to win a game
by defense alone sure defense matters
sure caution is important sure there's
it's good to have a strong defense but
the only way you can score
is when you're playing offense and so
really in recessionary times you have
two choices you can either be scared or
you could be prepared
and there's three responses to fear
flight you run away freeze you stop and
do nothing or fight you go on offense so
what are you going to choose are you
going to shrink back are you just going
to freeze and hope everything blows over
or are you going to fight and what I've
learned is that fear is a signal it's
actually your choice on how you react to
that signal do you run or do you fight
you know what will happen in recession
is a lot of things that happen in
culture is there is really Mass
psychosis really there is like masses of
people a lot of times move based on the
mainstream narrative but at the think
media podcast we do not give in to the
mainstream narrative we say that okay
everyone else might be playing defense
but we're going to stay on offense if
everybody else is in fear we're not
going to give in to fear we're going to
stay in faith and your action item for
this is to double down on content
creation
so literally this is a time to say what
does staying on offense mean for you as
a listener to this podcast it means a
doubling down of of creating content you
know back in 2020
when the lockdown started and when there
was so much political upheaval and so
much uncertainty and so much fear one of
the things that we observed was that a
lot of people froze a lot of people
shrunk back a lot of people froze and on
the one hand I want you to hear my heart
I'm empathetic that if there's so much
pressure around you and if your mental
health needs a break that maybe you
should take some time off however what I
noticed was that so many people lost
ground and one of the biggest things we
did in 2020 during that time at think
meteos was we stayed on offense I want
you to consider this as you go into 2023
how can you double down on content
creation what we did was while everybody
was shrinking back and things were
shutting down we actually started new
shows during that time we started the uh
coffee with candle show Heather started
the YouTube Made Simple show we started
to be even more intentional about
publishing content why because we want
to be top of mind and tip of tongue
because we want to be the go-to person
in our Niche that continues to Resource
people with information with
encouragement with content with strategy
so if you want to see your business
increase if you want to see online
Revenue increase you got to stay on
offense and think about how you can
publish more not less not how you can
shrink back and reduce your posting
schedule not how you can just freeze and
do nothing how can you fight and stay on
offense offense is your Recession Proof
strategy now think about it maybe your
YouTube channel is not monetized yet but
how do you ultimately make more revenue
from the YouTube Partner program you
post more videos and you get more views
maybe you're doing affiliate marketing
how do you get more Revenue you rank
more videos get more views and earn more
money from affiliate marketing so
offense is the only game to play in
content creation you can't just sit
around and rest on the videos you made
yesterday if they rank that's great
because you're still getting views but
you need to make videos today let me
speak to you as a business owner you
need to go all in on offense and you
need to go all in on YouTube I spoke
recently at my friend Ryan pineda's
event all about real estate and I had a
couple people come up to me after the
session who are video ranking Academy
students and they said hey Sean I got a
YouTube channel real estate agent and
they said uh I've got about a thousand
subscribers I've done five deals from my
real estate channel in my local market
my friend real estate is Frozen right
now transactions are crashing like crazy
right now so how did this individual
generate more sales in a very tough
market for real estate agents they're
creating content on YouTube so YouTube
is how you stay in the top 10 of agents
that are going to actually make it in
hard times see why some people freeze
and why some people run away you've got
to fight so if you're a business owner
while maybe different streams of Revenue
are drying up or different lead sources
are drying up you got to get creative
and stay on offense let me speak to
aspiring creators this next decade is
going to be the best decade on YouTube
but if you just wait another year if you
wait another two years before starting
or really getting serious about your
YouTube channel you're just gonna be
further behind you've got to stay on
offense and so I have action plans for
each of these there's these three
strategies and I actually have a fourth
bonus strategy for you so definitely
watch or listen until the end
but uh the first one is what is your
YouTube channel business plan for
staying on offense how do you actually
get prepared using this strategy for
2023 you make a plan
how many videos you get to post a week
are you starting a video podcast
how are you chopping up your longer form
videos into shorter form content is that
part of your strategy does YouTube
shorts come into a part of your strategy
who is your YouTube channel for and what
kind of content are you making for them
and how can you take that to another
level next year you know there's a book
I love it's called Rich Dad Poor Dad by
Robert Kiyosaki and Robert talks about
how his Poor Dad would say oh there's no
way we can afford that and as Rich Dad
would say how can we afford that like
where there's a will there's a way and I
bring that up related to creating more
content you might say there's no way I
could post more than I'm posting now I'm
already too busy no no you changed the
question how could I post more content
could I actually start raising revenue
now lowering expensive diverting energy
more towards hiring maybe somebody to
help editing a service to help me with
video editing how could I create more
content because if I'm meeting if I'm
making smart strategic content
that is connected to monetization
strategies or generating leads and sales
and customers for my business then more
of that smart strategic content is going
to lead to more business and maybe my
business doesn't grow maybe it just
helps me hold territory like a great
offense just means that I don't actually
get taken out and swept away when the
tide goes out but I'm actually able to
hold my ground why because I've got a
smart YouTube channel business plan now
if you actually want more on this I want
to let you know about a limited time
sale that we have on our video ranking
Academy program and some special bonuses
it's at
learnvideo2023.com and if you would say
that I'm serious about growing my
YouTube channel specifically next year
and I'm serious about putting together a
plan and step by step knowing what am I
going to do as far as content creation
what videos am I going to make getting
your YouTube channel strategy solid
learning everything we each with our 7R
system step by step as well as some
really cool bonuses I want to encourage
you if you're serious about YouTube
right now check out
learnvideo2023.com to see that special
offer it's something that we put out
just during our recent five-day
Challenge and so that is ending soon
that special offer is uh truly scarce
and so uh if that link no longer works
it either redirects to some other web
page or it'll give you a countdown to
that offer which is ending soon but
number two
it sees the opportunity so number one is
stay on offense number two is seize the
opportunity what do I mean
a recession is an opportunity for
Content creators
now I say this again with empathy I
understand that we're not celebrating
the fact of the economic pain or
hardship that's happening
but the truth is content creators are
uniquely positioned to benefit from
recession I recently interviewed Patrick
that David when I was at his offices in
Miami with Nolan malt on the think media
team and I asked him hey what do you
think is coming up when it comes to the
economy and he said oh there's going to
be a lot more pain with what the fed's
raising rates with you know the stock
market going down more housing market
could get hit another 10 20 percent even
more he's a real Financial expert I said
well what about for Content creators and
he goes oh content creators is going to
be a huge opportunity I said why is that
and he said well
one of the things that happens during
recession is spending on alcohol goes up
spending on entertainment goes up and
people spending time at home wanting to
consume more learn a new skill watching
free content YouTube content whether
they want to learn or be entertained
education or entertainment now whether
they pay for YouTube premium or not
remember once you cross that
monetization thread threshold you earn
money from views so he was like oh no
content creators are going to do amazing
in the next couple years especially
those that position themselves right
so number two sees the opportunity is
just this reminder
that you should double down on making
content and double down specifically on
YouTube content but when I specifically
mean the opportunity recession is an
opportunity for entrepreneurs you know
some of today's top companies started in
a recession did you know that The Joe
Rogan Experience Podcast started in
2009. fast forward to 2022 that's 13
years later and now Joe Rogan's a top
podcaster Spotify paid him 100 million
to go over there he still uploads his
Clips to his YouTube channel
you know Airbnb the Online Marketplace
started in 2008 MailChimp 2009 slack
2009 Apple
um had their restart they got their
second birth during the.com bubble of
2001 A recession but here's what Tim
Cook Apple's former CEO and current CEO
said he said we believe in investing
during downturns
so when you realize number one everyone
is in fear or they're shrinking back or
they're like let me just ride this out
you no you don't just ride this out you
stay on offense you invest during
downturns this is when
greatness is made this is when pressure
makes diamonds this is when Diamonds Are
Made think media
was also founded in 2010 in the midst of
an economic downturn and a recession and
so I want to encourage you to seize the
opportunity and if you haven't heard my
story before think media started
during the hardest season of my life and
of my family's life
we had we were my wife and I were
serving in Ministry we were interns at a
church helping you know a youth group
that every Wednesday we were serving at
Venture the church hired me like quarter
time so I was paid like I don't know
eight grand a year or something for uh
editing video for the church on the
weekends and not even for my youth
ministry duties I started a business
called clearvision media where I was
doing wedding videos and Hip-hop music
videos I was waiting tables at Red Robin
my wife was a Starbucks barista she was
a waitress at Anthony's in Mukilteo in
Washington
and we were dual income trying to pay
for our house which was on an 80 20 arm
loan these loans that I don't think
they're legal anymore uh because they
were given out during the bubble and my
wife got really sick in fact so sick
that she almost died and I've shared
this story a couple times before right
where uh she had a feeding tube she she
got in the Philippines on a trip back in
2007 what's called gastroparesis it
triggered in maybe getting food
poisoning triggered idiopathic
chronic illness called gastroparesis at
first doctors didn't know what it was
and so for a couple years she was losing
all this weight throwing up 10 to 15
times a day and eventually she had to
get a feeding tube they placed it wrong
in her stomach so instead of the liquid
food going into her stomach it was
filling up her whole body cavity which
will suffocate her organs and so crazy
story rush her to the hospital was spent
six days in the hospital by her side
during that time we're losing our home
and we had a rental property as well
we're losing that the tenant lost their
job so it was Total Carnage economically
around us my wife is no longer working
and we couldn't afford
to pay our mortgage because we each were
working multiple jobs to be able to do
that and then on top of that the church
that we are part of fell apart because
of leadership failures and some people
stealing some money so you want to talk
about like the compounding of pain and
hardship in our lives
and being truly in the midst of a
recession when we could have for sure
just ran away ran away and hid and just
like comfort and trying to escape
reality we could have ran away and or
just froze and said let's just rise this
ride this out but I want to speak into
your spirit on this podcast that friend
you can fight through this
when I look back I think it was my faith
in God it was my commitment to prayer
and the Bible was my commitment to
staying in church and it was my
commitment to our vision my commitment
to my wife and my commitment to to just
like I'm telling you in this podcast to
say what are my options here
to just shrink back to just wait and do
nothing or to keep fighting and I want
to encourage you burn the bridges there
are no other options you got to keep
fighting and so in that season I started
think media like I started something new
and maybe you haven't started your
YouTube channel yet I want to encourage
you now is the time to start maybe
you've been stuck Now's the Time to get
off the sidelines and start posting
content again and I want to encourage
you just like these other companies you
can be like one of these startups you
know listen I know that a lot of us
aren't going to become The Joe Rogan
Experience with zillions of listeners
but there is so many creators startups
that are now established today why
because they fought they did not flee
they did not you know freeze they fought
during hard times and you gotta seize
the opportunity the reason recession is
an opportunity is because maybe your
life slows down maybe you lose a job and
I know that you could be a afraid of
that that's an opportunity two ways to
look at any situation right the glass
could be half empty or the glass could
be half full
and you look at it like man I got a
little extra time on my hands or maybe
this particular thing you know the
church fell apart and we're losing our
homes and my wife is sick and I can look
at this this is real terrible stuff but
it's your opportunity to play the hand
you're dealt and especially now maybe
times are good seize the opportunity
here's what I also mean YouTube strategy
wise
um I interviewed do it on a dime a while
back so do it on a dime started her
YouTube channel in 2011. and what she
did was this again was still during a
lot of economic pain and hardship the
bubble head bursts real estate wise
America was reeling things were starting
to rebuild so she started a Channel
about saving money about couponing about
helping people be more efficient with
their finances and now a decade later
she has 2.1 million subscribers
here's my point
entrepreneurs solve problems for a
profit
so she saw a way to serve people solve
problems
answer specific questions create a
particular type of content that would
help people in a particular season
see while other people freeze and shrink
back in fear
content entrepreneurs listening to the
think media podcast that are courageous
and intelligent are going to start
YouTube channels or pivot their existing
YouTube channel or their content
strategy to serve and help people
see you could do you could run away from
Battle or you could run in and start
helping people picking up a weapon and
start taking territory your opportunity
during recession look there's still
problems to solve there's new problems
to solve
loan officers higher interest rates
there's new problems to solve real
estate agents markets more complex you
need a new skill set to help people
right as people are are at home maybe a
little bit more discouraged new
entertainment opportunities where people
are just looking for an outlet New this
there there is opportunities hidden in
every adversity and this is where I
promised you I said this was how I
turned adversity into an advantage
during the last recession the the
disruption of my life from all of these
negative circumstances became the fuel
for starting something new that today is
22 people on the think media team that
today is 2 million subscribers that
today is all from starting in this it
was something that was started during
the hardest season of my life and that
is your opportunity right now and by the
way at the time of listening to this
we don't really know what's going to
come next in the economy but a lot of
experts are saying pain is coming
hardship is coming so all I'm suggesting
is this is your time to get prepared
number one to stay on offense and number
two to seize the opportunity now I've
got the action step for this one and
then
um I've got number three and the bonus
one for you but here's the action and
it's a question how could you position
or reposition your business and plan to
serve the needs of people during an
economic downturn
so how could you position your business
or how could you reposition your
business if you're a business owner it
could be creating a new product thinking
about a different product it could be
thinking about pricing it's thinking
about how could you position yourself in
light of the psychology of what's
happening in people's minds of what's
happening in the economy How Could You
position or reposition your business to
serve the needs of people during an
economic downturn number three
invest in the assets
and reduce spending on liabilities
so as we prepare and this would be a
strategy this strategy right these are
three Recession Proof YouTube strategies
this is how you're spending your money
and what you're investing in
so what is an asset versus a liability
well an asset is something that helps
you make more money an asset is
something that is a tax write-off an
asset is something that's related to
your content creation business even if
you're not
really thinking that way yet we have a
three-part series because we have a lot
of tax episodes coming up on the think
media podcast to think about as a
content creator you are a small business
owner
you should start an LLC you should start
itemizing and keeping of course Good
Records
a liability is something that actually
hurts you
um meaning it just is a waste you can't
write it off it's just spending that is
on something that's not going to help
you go further faster
um something that just helps you escape
now at times of course entertainment
travel whatever but when you really
think about tough times investing in
assets is the move strategically so this
could be gear how can you position
yourself now to think about
building out your battle station okay
let me make it easier let me invest in
camera lighting USB microphone a
dedicated area of my home it could be a
home office
um how can I invest in my content
creation abilities one of my favorite
questions is if you're about to make a
purchase you should ask yourself is this
a write-off can it be a write-off on my
taxes
and if it can't you should second guess
spending on it and an asset investing in
your business if it's not wasteful I'm
not saying just buy a bunch of dumb gear
you're not going to use I'm saying buy
intelligent what kind of software could
you buy what kind of cameras what kind
of gear what kind of tools could help
you go further faster a computer a phone
you don't need the latest iPhone
but if you're if you're working off some
old Droid that's super slow and you're
trying to create content faster that
matters you want speed of content
creation
so invest in the tools necessary to do
the work and to get your creative work
done
investing in assets you can invest in
education one of the best investments
you can make Benjamin Franklin said it
this way this way an investment in
knowledge pays the best interest
some people say hey if I had five
hundred dollars a thousand dollars to
invest where should I put it should I
put it in the market maybe the Market's
going down right now where should I put
it you can't really buy a house for that
you can't get a loan that's not enough
money you should reinvest those dollars
when you have that kind of money in your
ability to produce more so that's why I
mean back in 2009 2010
I remember buying online courses on
online marketing I remember purchasing a
course from I'm going on his podcast
recently a guy named Dr Dave Martin that
was all a mindset I bought a course all
about like the millionaire mindset so I
could actually be consuming something
helpful at the time when there was all
this negativity around me I wanted to
invest in my mindset in my education in
my skill set buying books see an
investment in yourself
and knowledge pays the best interest
investment in your network
you know I'm not suggesting you have to
do this or that this would even be right
for you but recently I flew to Miami
which and I flew Nolan to Miami to do a
meet up to shoot a podcast to be on
another podcast
um to tour uh valuetainment which is
Patrick Beth David's offices because we
eventually want to start offices like
that at think media in Las Vegas
um and that was all at our own expense
and of course we got the the episode the
podcast episode uh it was a deep
experience for Nolan as we got to spend
time together and he's the content
director of think media now and so us
spending more leadership time together
here's my point you may be in a Solo
Creator season so apply this to your
season but for me that was a big I mean
we're spending food we're spending
airfare we're spending hotel but it was
the best investment we can make and the
entire trip is a write-off because the
whole thing was a business trip and
pretty cool I mean we get to go to Miami
and we're eating Cuban food at you know
the Bayside Marketplace and I mean we're
also we've built a business around our
lifestyle around what we love to do it's
pretty rad that we are ubering around
town and drinking coffee meeting up with
creators and meeting up with some of our
YouTube boot camp members and all kinds
of stuff it was really cool but all that
all of that investment was an investment
in ourselves it was an investment in our
Network it was an investment in our
education it was an investment in
content
so an asset could be gear it could be
education it could be courses it could
be different things for your learning it
could be plane tickets it could be
events and those things check with your
CPA but those can all be write-offs an
investment in another pair of shoes
especially in times like this who cares
you don't need those right an investment
in uh just a bunch of stuff that is not
going to help you plus may not be a
write-off in your taxes this would be
the time to invest in assets and reduce
spending on liabilities and so invest in
skills and here's a question for you a
couple action items what skills do I
need to survive and thrive in the new
economy
what skills do I need
as I Look to 2023 and Beyond what skills
do I need to not just survive but also
to thrive in a changing economy in a
down economy in an uncertain economy
remembering that in recession the money
doesn't go away it just changes hands in
a recession some businesses shrink but
some grow in a recession some people
struggle others Thrive so what is the
difference those who have a different
skill set those who have different
levels of knowledge those who are have a
better Network investing in your network
is getting around the right people
getting in the right rooms or getting in
the right online communities and so your
action item for number three before we
do the bonus one is what liabilities
could you cut
what liabilities could you cut
some real easy ones that especially in a
time like this uh it's a good time to
cut drinking it's a good time to cut
weed it's a good time to cut sugar
like again A lot of times I get it you
want to escape
maybe think about some of the live is
that an asset or a liability it's a good
time to cut those things that are
stealing your it's a good time to cut
staying up all night watching junk
content is a good time to invest in
assets sleep health
by the way health is a huge asset to
think about dollars spent I I always
think of dollars invested in my health
whether that's nutritious food whether
that's supplements whether that's red
light therapy I mean buying red light
panels things like that so what
liabilities could you cut this is a
YouTube strategy
friend if you cut liabilities
you're cutting dead weight you're
cutting things that are slowing you down
you're cutting things that are holding
you back going into 2023 and then what
assets could you invest into to set
yourself up for success
work how could you reallocate dollars I
will encourage you when people
run right they just shrink back
the the bad move is people who pull
their money out of the market when it's
down I've known people unfortunately
people I'm very close to who in 2008
panicked
pulled their money out of 401ks the
stock market when if they and they
didn't need to retire at the time and
they had got absolutely crushed because
they didn't ride it out that was the
wrong time to run
it would have been better to just wait
but the smart people actually go on
offense a dollar cost average into the
market they invest when it's down they
buy assets that are distressed so what
could you invest into what everybody
else is moving away running away you
invest into things that'll set you up to
for success I want to encourage you want
to be very intelligent about where
you're putting your money but it is
smart to still deploy your money what
happens when people are afraid they
don't invest the money when it's a smart
time to actually be very strategic with
your finances I know it's scary a lot of
times you wouldn't think oh Now's the
Time to build a battle station well if
you're going to use it it's going to be
a waste if you build out your YouTube
battle station and you just sit on it
that's not what I'm suggesting at all
I'm saying you're committed to making a
show you're committed to weekly content
you're committed to all of the above
well then you want to invest in assets
that are going to help you go further
faster what assets could you invest into
to set you up for success all right
bonus tip number four as we land the
plane
this one I had to add on here because it
is definitely a huge strategy for how
can you Recession Proof your uh business
your YouTube plan and it's protect your
mindset
I know when you think strategies you
think tactics of course you should be
investing in short form content YouTube
shorts are going to get 45 you know
monetization that's super interesting
um if you go back in the podcast
archives we did an episode about two big
opportunities that is short form and
long form but this is strategic in my
mind because your mind is your greatest
asset
protect your mindset
okay
I'm I wanted to get this podcast into
your hands
into your phone into your tablet
wherever you listen or watch this
because your mindset matters so much
and you gotta protect your mindset
especially when the mainstream narrative
in the mainstream news and and maybe
your friends and maybe your peers and
everybody around you is just operating
in fear or in scarcity or on defense or
on negativity and what's Wild is of
course while there's truth to that the
opposite is also true
while some people are stuck in
negativity there's plenty of people who
are being positive
for for people that you can find that
are stuck in scarcity there's people who
are still living in abundance
and I'm not trying to speak at all from
an entitled place here
I recognize my position today but I
would say that back in 2009 I've got
some credibility in 2010 we couldn't
have been in more scarcity this is the
scarcest time of my life we were
absolutely crushed health is scarce
wealth is scar scarce friends we had
destruction all around us but I chose to
operate in an abundant mindset
I chose to think big in small places I
chose my perspective your attitude is a
choice your perspective is a choice so
protect your mindset practically who
you're around matters
I think it's it's it's smart to audit
your circle going into 2023.
what you watch matters you are what you
eat
if you're watching fear porn YouTube
videos or Instagram reels and tick tocks
and what do I mean by that if you just
are swiping just to watch negative news
and negative economic reports and
negative this and that it's good to stay
informed but you really got to ask
yourself what did you really learn or
how did that really help you if all it
did was negatively affect your
psychology and your mindset then you
just disempowered yourself to maybe if
you're watching content that is feeding
a Why Try Spirit Well I even try
you know I started posting some videos
for a couple months but the whole
world's melting and everything's falling
apart around me man why even try yeah
sure enough confirms what I thought you
know Uncle Ed was saying the same thing
uh the next two years are gonna suck
sure enough like why even try
like that's not helpful whereas if you
get around people who are possibility
thinkers not impossibility thinkers are
people around you just saying why even
try
you know to post content on YouTube
why even why even try to break through
and it's so crowded now
there's just no who do you even think
you are impossibility thinkers will pull
you down negativity and fear is
contagious but guess what
courage is also contagious
you got to protect your mindset and I
just want to encourage you to say that
especially during recessionary periods
you know I remember back in those days
the way I predicted my mindset was first
what I chose to listen to again I
remember I told you I purchased a
program for my now friend Dr Dave Martin
who who just had me thinking possibility
had me thinking Solutions had me
thinking learning I was buying I bought
it these days there were CDs right I
know it's all mp3s and Spotify I bought
a Communications program off of eBay I
was learning from Chris Weidner and John
Maxwell because I wanted to get better
as a communicator a skill set I was
sharpening my skills I was investing in
auditory resources like these days you
have Audible so you can just grab
audiobooks there was no audible so I was
investing in things that were going to
feed my courage feed my faith for me I
was staying planted in church even
though I didn't want to because of all
the drama that was happening in my
church I stayed planted I I was
Investing For Me in reading the Bible
feeding my spirit I was investing I was
around possibility thinkers one of those
was Jeff Moore's who today is a church
planner in Oceanside California and we
both were living in Marysville before he
moved to Oceanside and and it was like
iron sharpens iron he was a faith friend
it was somebody who again courage is
contagious it was like Jeff we actually
started this project back then called
think International the reason think
media today is called think media that's
because we started this YouTube channel
called think International where we were
interviewing uh church leaders and
faith-based leaders and authors and um
he was kind of like if you know the
biblical story Jonathan and his armor
Bearer he was like dude let's do
something let's like go up and fight
these Philistines see see if this works
out like maybe God will be on our side
maybe we'll be able to maybe we'll win
maybe we will maybe we won't and the
armor bearer was like all right dog
let's like you know let's write it down
giddy up
you need those kind of people in your
life courage is contagious and as we
started that and as I used the gear and
I took out a loan to start my business
clearvision media
camera gear and all that stuff we use
that gear to start think International I
started getting questions about what
cameras are you using how are you
producing these videos how do you edit
your videos and I was like I should
start like a media angle of this
and I called it think media TV at the
time right and so I started something
back to seize the opportunity and back
to stay on the offense I started
something
in the midst of a negative time because
I was also around someone positive I had
Jeff in my life I had my wife and my
life even though she's going through
health challenges or whatever we are
Faith people and there was depressed
weeks right there's tough weeks there's
tough times and there was bills piling
up and stuff hitting us and definitely
drama in our lives but we had to choose
watch listen to protect your mindset we
had to choose
to feed our faith and starve our fears
here's your action items
who should you spend less time with
listen I know sometimes this could be
delicate not saying that you've got
friends or family members that are maybe
toxic or super negative
here is your option you can set
boundaries
you can limit your time okay if you
haven't read Dr Henry Cloud's book
boundaries that's a good one to be
thinking about there's certain people
where you're not going to maybe cut them
out of your life their friends or family
members but it's your choice of how you
spend time
and if you get busy about your vision
and you get busy about your dreams and
you get your calendar packed with
content creation and with Innovation and
with ideation and within and and with
being on offense
during these coming years friends what
you can build it reminds me of the Dave
Ramsey quote live today like no one else
so that later in life you can live like
no one else
there's going to be some people and I
pray it's you listening to this even
right now there's going to be some
people
who this is the worst two to three years
of their life and there's going to be
some people who this is the best two to
three years of their life that sets them
up for the next 20 to 30 years
that might sound extreme but literally
what you do during this moment
if you choose not to run you choose not
to freeze but you choose to fight
what you do can set you up for the next
decade and Beyond
so you get to choose where should you be
spending less time
what should you stop watching
just not helpful right now I got to put
that away right now what should you stop
watching that habit what what should you
stop doing it's not helpful right now I
got to put that away right now this is
the time where I'm a little too fragile
my emotions are too fragile this there's
I need to be clear-headed I need to be
clear thinking I need to be locked in I
gotta I gotta Focus right now what
should you stop watching I I can't feed
off that negativity I shouldn't my
routine is every night I turn on the
news that news is not really helping me
because all I do is I'm informed with
information that I couldn't change
anyways
instead of doing that I'm going to lean
into some education I'm gonna turn off
the the news I'm going to turn on a
program an audio book an online course
something that's actually going to help
me skill up and that's going to feed my
courage what people places communities
are most beneficial for your mindset
that's the final action question
what people who can you double down with
and create an alliance with right now
any office listeners Watchers Jim and
Jim goes to Dwight do you want to form
an alliance Dwight goes to Jim and Jim
goes absolutely I do right they form an
alliance who should you honestly form an
alliance with you go man I mean I really
want to invest in that relationship
because that is a courageous person and
whenever I'm around them uh you know how
can I how can I get around to more how
can we collab more how can we build that
out where what places what communities
what communities online
I know you might feel like Sean I don't
have anyone in my local community
That's The Power of online communities
could be a Facebook group Discord it
could be you know a podcast like this
being very selective what is your weekly
routine of feeding your courage
what people places communities are most
beneficial to your mindset my friend
these are a couple ideas it's really for
recession-proof YouTube strategies for
2023 and uh I've got one more tip for
you but today's episode is brought to
you by uh learn video
2023 that's learn
video2023.com and uh that is a limited
time offer this I recorded this during
our challenge week and we're doing a
five day challenge you may or may not
have heard about that and at any given
time during the year we do have a
program called video rated Academy but
only three times this year we only did
three challenges we do a special uh
offer on it so if you've been on the
fence maybe you've heard about before uh
if if that's not something you're
interested in don't even worry about it
but if you've been hearing about all of
our success students with video ranking
Academy and you would say this I'm
serious about starting Reviving or
growing my YouTube channel in 2023 then
um this is by far the best offer of the
year when it comes to the bonuses and
the price and everything else so that's
learnvideo2023.com if you want to see
those details that is truly a limited
offer so check that out
um
I got one other thing to say uh to share
with you but if you're on YouTube it
would mean the world to me if you hit
the like button subscribe to the thick
media podcast on audio or video and if
this episode specifically added fuel to
your fire or you have a big takeaway or
an aha moment it would mean the world to
me if you dropped
um a review on Apple podcast that's the
best place to give us feedback if you
are getting value out of the think media
podcast only takes a minute or two and
you can give it a star rating and maybe
give me some feedback about any episode
or specifically this episode final thing
stay cool and collected
no matter what you do
keep your head on your shoulders stay
cool and collected great leaders keep
perspective maintain Clarity and remain
calm When Storms Brew
I don't know everything that's coming in
the next couple years I know that I'm
not going to be scared I'm going to get
prepared I know that I'm not going to
run away I'm going to run into the fight
I'm going to be wise
but I'm still going to take calculated
risks that's what entrepreneurs do
because being on offense means stepping
out of our comfort zones and especially
as content creators it means punching
fear in the face punching perfectionism
in the face and pressing record so I
want to thank you for being a part of
our think media podcast Community thanks
for checking out this episode share this
maybe with somebody that needs to hear
this message and I look forward to
seeing you of course every Tuesday for
our official episode drop on the podcast
whether you listen to it on YouTube or
audio until then my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel and we will
talk soon
foreign